two uninhabited Pacific Islands more than 5,000 miles from the UK one will be inhabited by 14
British men while a separate island will be home to 14 British women for six weeks they
will be utterly alone with only the clothes they stand up in fishing equipment and a handful of
basic tools filming everything themselves when pushed to the limits of human endurance will it
be brute power or mental strength the winds a day daddy brought home the Baker who will have
what it takes to stay alive tonight is the final installment of the women's I don't want to be on
camera today anybody
survival will be harder than ever the search for food is now a matter of life and death
it's a joke living on the island in the middle of tropical storm season
I think we are on our last leg when pitted against the extremes of nature with the finishing line in
sight these Monday women are
they just sleeping on a bit of ice an april 18th it's just a cold slide you've got to find
the hot potato first've got what it takes to survive I'll do what I'm wanting to do
I understand and go I'm not going to do it let me finish as usual arguments of the staff seeds
why cant you fucking know here and the baby fucking soon
After nearly five weeks of heat followed by a haberdam program which was a result of the
on the island the ten remaining women were on the verge of failure they were
dangerously dehydrated and had an urgent medical warning all the plug on this
that their lives were at risk in scary territory where we just don't know
what's happening to our bodies but they pulled themselves back from the brink
now entering their sixth week surviving on the island food in the camp vicinity
is running out the starving women face a battle to make it to the end
desperate for something to eat
Becky
Julie
and Georgie brave the vicious incoming tide to scavenge the last remaining oysters.
Oh, bloody hell. Today I'm feeling like absolute shit. I know that I keep saying I feel like
shit, but today I feel like dried white dog poo shit.
Since they've arrived on the island, the starving women have shed more than 140 pounds.
between them. The weight of an average woman.
Our coconut supply is running low. Our yucca around here is non-existent. The limes have
now gone. The almond fruits that grow on the trees here, we've eaten all of those.
Oh, they stink.
For six weeks, vegetarian Jamie has been surviving on nothing but nuts and coconuts.
As soon as I get off here, I need to get as much protein in me as I can.
Yeah.
I just had a day, but you'll get a big fat sausage in you as soon as you get off here.
Sometimes I do eat meat, but only the sausage variety. Sometimes I like a bit of chorizo,
but I don't like them chipolatas.
Here, let me help you.
With food so scarce around camp, the rest of the women are having to rely solely on
the fishing net they've set in the shallows.
Oh, I think that's something in the net.
It's a shark.
Where is it? Where is it? Where is it?
That is unbelievable.
All right, got him. Quick, he's getting away.
No, he's got a way. He's got a way. He's got a way.
Oh, damn. Damn, damn, damn.
No supper for us tonight.
There's 10 of us, and I think we are on our last legs.
I think we are on our last legs.
When Mother Nature slams that larder door firmly shut,
things in a group can rapidly go downhill.
You're hungry, you're despondent, and it's so tempting to give up.
But like so many things in life and in the wild,
it's actually about how you respond to those crisis moments.
I've literally been up almost all night just trying to keep that fire alive.
From day one, the women have governed themselves in a leaderless community,
trying to make group decisions.
What, was there not enough wood? Have we run out of wood now?
We ran out of wood last night, and everyone went to...
You're joking. Yeah.
People just know they need to fucking get wood.
End of story. That's the bit that I don't get.
There's no leader. Not one person rules the roost.
We work collectively, so we have to kind of use our initiative
and work off the average.
So if, say, I want to go foraging,
I don't have to be told to go foraging.
I'm going to go foraging.
All the decisions we've made thus far have been made elaboratively.
We've not needed to conform to a system where there's a leader.
The women need to survive seven more days on the island.
Any hope of dinner depends entirely on catching fish.
The women are yet to be found.
It's time to establish a rota for checking the nets,
and Julie has made a discovery.
The net is in a right mess.
It's just... It's curled over that tight.
There's no teamwork.
There's no organisation.
There's... Nobody wants responsibility for anything.
Holy shit. It's an absolute state.
I mean, have you seen that?
It's crested, it's crested, it's crested.
High, stormy seas have destroyed their last hope
of getting something to eat.
Fishing is the only thing that we survive off at the minute.
We need to get it sorted ASAP.
It's just getting more and more tangled.
Yeah, I know, but just pulling it like that's going to rip it, isn't it?
No, it's not.
Well, it is when... I can feel it.
Well...
I'll just wait until we've used it.
Stop being a stroppy cow, Jamie. What's up with you?
Where's Jamie gone?
Fucking want to get fucking off here.
It better be fucking soon.
I would say I've had a hard life growing up.
My mum's got MS and she's been in a care home.
She's always said to me to basically live life to the full
because she's never been able to do the things that I've done.
It's made me...
It's made me extremely independent.
So if someone was to start bossing me about,
it would make me really upset and probably make me really angry.
I'll do what I want, when I want.
I don't want anybody telling me what to do, bossing me about.
Fed up.
We have to do things that, you know, we don't always want to do,
but it's for the team.
I've had enough of fucking everything!
It really is shit!
If anything's going to make me leave this island,
it's the people.
It's not like a team work.
Well, darling, I mean, I don't know what to say to you other than,
you know, I completely agree.
I thought we were all going to be a team and pull together and...
It's not like that at all, is it?
It's absolutely not like that at all.
The effects of starvation on the body are not just physical.
Extreme hunger makes people desperate, depressed, irritable,
and all the negative emotions that women are experiencing
will be amplified.
And if there are rifts emerging now, what hunger will do,
it will act like a crowbar, forcing those rifts further apart.
So, what's everybody doing? Can we just make it clear?
Nobody's taken responsibility to set a fire rotor,
so it's left to Beth and Lauren again to keep the embers going through the night.
I'm sorting out the fire. You're sorting out your socks.
While Jamie has slept.
I think you should help.
Right, well, do you know what I can't be doing with this?
Literally, you've got to bend over and get a fucking twig.
Well, just stop fucking bossing me about, right?
Look, there's Rose here.
I want to show my daughter that I can be brave.
I want to show her that there are endless possibilities
and a woman can do anything.
I'm hoping we're all going to group together and be a team,
especially because it's just a group of women.
I think we've all got a little bit of something to prove.
I will help when I'm ready.
I've been up all night with the frigging fire.
And I'm tired too.
And you're saying...
You're sitting there sorting out your fucking feet.
I've got socks on.
Whatever.
Fucking laziness. It's outrageous.
It's absolutely outrageous.
We're all a bit fed up with Jamie. There, I've said it.
It's really making me frustrated.
And...
..every time I stop,
I feel like people are looking at me.
Actually, you know,
I didn't mean to hurt anyone's feelings and...
I don't know, but I think we're going to end up killing each other
by the end of this, I really do.
We are completely dysfunctional as a group.
I find that deeply upsetting and deeply frustrating
that we're led by mush.
We need a leadership to get ourself together,
to get our food sorted,
and we just can't live from this sort of hand-to-mouth,
piecemeal way.
More thought needs to be going into this, for sure.
Lauren and Beth call an emergency meeting.
We're working for democracy and, you know, things are pretty positive.
Something...something has gone wrong somewhere.
What do you think has gone wrong?
We're literally starved.
The group feels fragmented and that we're not a unit.
I don't know how that fire's managed to keep going.
It's literally by luck and coincidence that we keep rocking up,
going, oh, fuck, the fire's literally just about to go out,
and, oh, God, I've just got that jab of water.
You know, it's basically lack of structure
because then we have lack of food and it's kind of a knock-on effect.
I think, personally, we need to decide on a leader
to set out what is needed and a plan of action.
I can hear you're really passionate, Georgie, and I totally get it,
but I think, for me, we collapse.
For me, we collaboratively lead the group.
Harvey, that system is not working because we've done that
and I think we're stumbling from one day to the next
and now we're in crises.
I'm with Harvey here. Why is it necessary to have the leader?
Because the leader knows where everything is.
The leader will lead you and go, right, OK, these are the priorities.
Why should I let somebody boss me about and tell me what to do?
I'll do what I want to do.
You cannot stand there and go, I'm going to do what I want to do
and if someone's telling me what to do, I'm not going to do it.
But we all need to come together.
Exactly, the arguments have started already.
It's not an argument, Jamie.
This is what happens when you try and elect leaders.
SHE GASPS
This is what I didn't want.
I know, I know.
The last few days.
This is what I didn't want.
Trying to improve their destructive group dynamic,
it is important for the women.
Now they've turned on each other,
they've pushed their very survival back into jeopardy
and without decisive leadership, they won't make it to the end.
I'm so torn. I'm torn.
I think the fact that we're so torn
means that there isn't ever going to be a leader.
I want a double cheeseburger with extra cheese,
extra gherkins, onions, a little bit of lettuce, tomato,
just for good measure.
It's the final week on the island.
Food is scarce and the women are starving.
Age. Don't talk about food.
What's the new rule we say?
Penis, penis, penis. Penis, penis, penis.
Just say that instead. It'll stop you thinking about it.
That's why I'm down today. I'm craving food.
Penis.
We're in a really shit situation
and there has to be someone that's ballsy enough
to grab the ball by the horns and go,
do you know what, guys, this is what we need to do.
MUSIC PLAYS
A violent storm is pummeling the island.
Is Jamie still out there?
Yeah, she's having some time now.
Most of the women are sheltering under the fire canopy,
but one of them has removed herself from the group.
Jamie's still toughing it out on the beach.
MUSIC CONTINUES
Soaping wet knickers. Isn't that the definition of sexy?
It's been a broken night's sleep, lying on the wet ground.
I'm like a fucking elephant, man.
It's really not that bad.
The rain has brought her back to the beach,
but she's not feeling too well.
The rain has brought an onslaught of insect attacks.
I do not want to be on camera today.
If anybody films me, I'll kick off.
The insect bites are driving me round the fucking bend.
I'd like to punch each fly in the nose.
We had something to fuck off biting us last night
and I had bites all over my arse.
Bloody ridiculous.
Basically get rid of all this shit on the roof.
Painful, itchy bites aren't their only problem.
I mean, there literally is a twig holding that fucking lot up.
The storm has wreaked havoc in camp.
That don't look good, honey.
The desperate hunt for food has to be put on hold
as the canopy protecting the fire is on the verge of collapse.
Is that big crack there running along the middle of it? Yeah.
How are you getting on? Slow.
But it's better than what we've got, right?
Which is zero right now.
To shield them from insects and rain,
Jamie and Georgie have decided to build a raised bed with a roof.
It's a very busy camp today
to make sure we have a good shelter for us.
And our fire is as dry as a boat.
All hands on deck.
Down, down, down, down, down, down, there.
That's it, you got it.
Shall I go that end and push? Yeah.
Where's everybody gone?
I think Harvey and...
Me and Jamie are having a lie down.
It's just got too serious.
And I know we've got jobs to do,
but why is there so much pressure all of a sudden?
Guys, we haven't finished!
I know, I know we're not finished.
I was actually just having a little bit of a rest.
Ah! So give me a break, please.
I'm not saying that. I'm just saying you haven't finished.
That's all. Right.
Just whack them all on now.
Oh, God.
I'm sorry.
I think I might go on strike tomorrow.
Let's get this roof on, guys, and then we can have a proper tidy.
I'm going to kill myself with these fucking rockets.
While the rest of the group toil away on the bed shelter...
..Jamie and Belinda decide to take the afternoon off.
I kind of feel a little bit like, you know when someone comes into your house
and takes a massive shit in your toilet, eats all your food, messes your house,
and then leaves and goes, ''Bye now!''
We have been upset and tired and angry,
and so there's only so long that those things can go on for
until you have to do something.
So we have to change it.
If we're not happy, then do something about it.
Beth and Lauren take decisive action.
They call an election.
Jamie!
Hi.
Hi, love.
We're having a meeting.
Clothes are optional.
I find Jamie so unpredictable.
I don't know if she's going to shrug it off and just say, ''Oh, do you know what, whatever,''
or if she's going to kick off about it.
All the great expeditions have always had a leader,
whether it's Amazon, Scott or Shackleton,
but resistance to leadership is not uncommon.
We've called this meeting today...
..because not much has changed
and most people still want a leader.
If anybody would like to go for leadership,
please make yourself be known.
Me and Beth.
I'm confused, to be honest.
What's so bad?
We need a leader so everyone knows exactly what they're doing.
You know my feelings on the leadership.
Not happy with it.
Our whole experience has been amazing
and so I just want to end on success
and it means a lot, I think, to show that we never gave up.
Yeah. Yeah.
I so get you.
I so want Bear to come and look at our camp and think,
''Crikey, those girls were good.''
Do we need to take a vote?
I think we should just go forwards with it
because you're the only people who want to do it.
You're happy to go with Beth and Lauren?
Are people happy with that?
Jamie?
Yeah.
Lauren and Beth are going to run the leadership jointly.
After all of that, well done.
Thank you.
Be proud of yourselves.
Yeah.
I was so nervous leading up to it.
I was just thinking, ''Oh, my God, how's this going to be taken?''
Especially after the other day.
But, actually, it seemed pretty positive.
We need to just straighten out this end.
The new leader's first priority is to feed everyone.
We are now going to move the nets, basically,
at a different angle in the sea.
So, hopefully, we can get a fish.
Yeah.
We can get a fish.
Together, the women have untangled the vital fishing net.
OK. Keep it up.
They're now determined to finally land a big catch.
I think the net is great.
I think at least we're trying.
I think God loves to try it.
I think that Jamie is just feeling undervalued,
that sort of thing.
With all ten women needed to tackle a food crisis,
Lauren has to bring Jamie back into the fold.
We need every single one of those girls in the group
to get through this.
I know what it feels like to fail
at something that you give your all to,
and I'm not prepared to go through that again.
I probably picture myself as a bit of a young leader.
In 2013, I decided to row across the Atlantic.
But the boat capsized, I split my head open.
The failure of the row just left a huge void in me.
And then I thought, yep,
the island is definitely something I want to do.
This is definitely how I'm going to get it back.
I always give my everything to whatever challenge I set myself.
So when I fail, I feel...
I feel that in a big way.
Jay? Jamie?
So, I just want to clear the air.
I was feeling like you weren't helping out,
but what I should have done, absolutely what I should have done,
is come and talk to you about it.
I remember I woke up with them bites all over my face,
and that put me in a sort of vicious cycle
where I was, like, just not enjoying being here
and not motivated to do anything.
Get more involved. If you want to do stuff, like...
I do sometimes feel like I can't be arsed.
SHE LAUGHS
Oh, no!
I'm sorry.
I...
..probably come across selfish,
but I hope that they can...
..understand that I didn't mean to hurt anyone's feelings and...
..I don't want to leave, you know, this island
feeling sour and bitter.
So, I think we're here. Yeah.
So, this is our beach.
Lauren's plan now is to search for food
beyond the confines of their beach.
We go up that track until we hit that middle path. Correct.
Then we go down with the sea.
Always on our left-hand side.
She leads a hunting party deep into the jungle.
See you later.
Along the coast...
SHE SCREAMS
Oh! My nail got stuck in this fucking gooey bat!
..vegetarian Jamie has volunteered to scavenge for limpets
to feed the rest of the group.
Oh, my God. Honestly, what is that?
Oh!
SHE SCREAMS
Anything?
Does that look rotten to you?
Yeah, yeah, an animal's been at it.
We've got snails the size of your head.
Woo-hoo! Shut the front door.
Wow!
The women on the other side of the island
are still on the hunt for yucca.
It would really suck to have come all of this way
and not find yucca.
Guys, I've just found a tin of something.
Whoa!
It might be a tin of peaches.
Oh, my God.
Thanks, baby.
SHE SCREAMS
Oh, my God!
That's going to make everyone super happy.
Yeah.
Guys!
Chloe!
We found two tins of baked beans!
You found beans?
SHE SCREAMS
The rusty tins are packed with protein and sugar
and may have been left by a hunting party from another island.
It's a lucky find.
Tonight, my dear, we have got a baked bean.
I can't wait.
I can't wait to eat it.
Oh!
What is in the tin?
Oh, wow!
It couldn't be better news for Jamie,
who survived on nothing but coconuts for weeks.
Fucking hell.
Oh, my God!
Is that not the nicest baked bean you've ever had in your life?
Beans!
You've actually turned the day around completely.
Thank you very much, Jamie.
Yeah, that was really sweet.
I've never been so excited about baked beans in all my life.
Oh, my God, this is amazing! This is amazing!
Oh, my God, what are we doing passing it round?
I can't even begin to tell you how good they are.
Oh, my God!
Sweet, yummy.
Tasty, tasty. Protein.
Thank you so much, girls.
From today onwards,
we're going to try and think about what needs to be done
to get the whole group to kind of work as one machine
to a point where we do have enough food.
It's Jamie's first belly-filling meal on the island.
Come on!
It's been six weeks!
No, it's been longer than that.
Oh, do you know what? Do you want to hear a funny story?
Oh, my God, this is hilarious.
As a dental technician, you know, like, the mould that you take of the teeth?
Well, you can use that stuff for also taking an impression of your cock.
That ex-boyfriend came round for dinner.
It was going on and on and on.
I want you to do my willy, I want you to do my...
Honestly, I've still got it to this day,
this big stone plaster cast of a willy.
Wow!
And it's like a lethal weapon, it weighs a tonne.
LAUGHTER
I personally have struggled.
Jesus, I have struggled.
But you know what?
To everyone that thought I wasn't going to survive...
..I'm here still.
Hiya!
6am.
We are on our way to catch some fishes.
Leaders Lauren and Jamie
and Lauren and Beth decide the time has come
for an all-out assault to conquer the island.
For the survivor, determination is a critical one
and I love that Winston Churchill quote that sums it up.
It just says, never, ever, ever quit.
Oh, that is beautiful.
So far, a big fish haul has eluded them.
The women are now praying their plan to reposition the net
has been successful.
I would give anything for there to be fish in this net now.
I'm scared, I don't want to look.
I'm in fear of disappointment.
Oh, what was that?
What have we got? What have we got?
So far, we've got two catfish, one other fish, two stingrays.
Yes!
LAUGHTER
I'm so happy.
Give me!
Yes!
She'll have a fishy on a little dishy
She'll have a fishy...
Another stingray! Two!
Awesome work, awesome work.
So happy, it makes you so happy,
like, to know that you're going to eat.
That worry's not there now.
But it's sort of proved
that our survival skills aren't that bad
and we can make it work.
Yeah.
I do miss toilet seats.
Yeah, I can't wait to have a poo in the toilet.
Three days left on the island.
Guys, what's the plan for today?
We need two people to do water collection, ASAP.
I don't mind doing it again.
We just need to get shitloads of wood.
Then we're going to get on to cleaning this area,
cos it's gross.
Top plan, I love a plan.
Five minutes.
Lauren's new daily rota is galvanising the women.
Lauren, what are we doing?
Sweeping away the leaves.
Cos we're girls and we like a clean floor.
I'm going to put this over your head.
Oh, my God!
Get the camera down!
We've started to line the entrance with coconuts.
Now what we need is some candles.
Oh, wouldn't that be great?
Oh, wouldn't that be dreamy?
Seashell bunting.
It's absolutely beautiful.
I love making stuff.
That'll cost a fortune back home.
These guys can come together, they can look after each other,
they can build community,
they can find that kind of something inside that drives them on,
that positive stuff.
But also, ultimately, they're not just surviving,
they're now learning to thrive.
And that's when you kind of see the magic.
We've got enough food now, we've got enough water,
we've kept the fire going, and so our priority now is shelter.
Oh, here's a big bastard.
A big jobby.
Until that boat rocks up on this shore,
we're going to be tidying up, organising,
so it's about pride,
and it's wanting to show to the world
that what the majority of females are made of
and what we're capable of doing with nothing.
Oh, my God!
It's like a tent, isn't it?
Ooh!
Oh-ho!
Oh, God, it's nice, you know. It's a bit noisy.
Yeah, but... Oh, God, but it's comfortable.
Oh, it's lovely.
That is mega-wow!
I could rest my bones here for a while, me thinks.
And teamwork.
It's nice that we've all built something together, you know?
And I think it's amazing and awesome.
Carnival!
We'll take it to Rio.
Beth and Lauren's vision for how the island should run began.
Jesus, how much better is it?
I cannot begin to tell you.
Babes, come outside, I've got a present for you.
OK, close your eyes.
What is it?
Ready?
You fucking bitch!
I knew it was something like that!
I know you, you little bitch.
Relationships are renewed.
The camp is now secure and comfortable,
and finally there's food on the table.
This is our first lunch.
Now we've worked it out,
and I really think we have worked out how to do it.
Yay!
We've survived.
And most of all, now we are thriving.
Is the tide coming in or going out?
Coming in.
Becky, Lauren and Beth brave the morning tide
to fetch water for the camp.
We made it!
Whoo!
As they head back, Lauren and Beth
make a discovery.
Becky!
Oh, look what we found here!
Oh!
Oh, hi there!
Come and join me, ladies.
Yay!
Lauren plans to use a washed-up polystyrene block
as a raft to make the exhausting daily water run
easier and quicker.
Are you kidding me?
What?
The Vader raft?
That is amazing!
Whoo!
I never, ever thought it was going to be
as hard as it has been.
If I can complete this, then I know within myself
that I didn't fail at rowing across the Atlantic.
And I need that.
I need that closure.
I need that feeling that I am strong enough
within myself to finish something.
We come with water.
This hand is next to the navy.
Bear grouse can bugger off.
We've got Lauren.
We're fine.
I'm coming!
With the fight for survival mastered,
they can now embrace the island's delights.
Great swim!
I think in both survival and in life,
you know, good things and worthwhile things
don't always come easy.
And for those that can endure on the island,
there will come a time when they will be able
to make the most of it.
And I think that's what we're going to do.
I'm sure on the island there will come a sense of pride
that money really can't buy, you know,
and it's a pride that will have been hard earned
through heart, through grit and through endeavour.
What are we up to?
We're going to check the net and...
Crab hunting!
Woo-hoo!
So excited!
As their days on the island draw to a close,
the women are seizing every opportunity to get food.
Quick, quick, quick, quick, quick!
Oh!
Julie's got a big one!
Right, got him!
Give us that bucket!
Yeah, go on, get him in, yeah!
In, in, in!
Woo!
You got another one?
Yeah!
Oh!
Julie!
Don't let him into your bucket!
He's in, he's in, he's in.
Great, great.
He's a fucking monster, that one.
Yeah.
Julie, you've turned into an absolute animal.
Get in there.
Oh, my God.
What's happened to me?
I was a lady in the pool.
To follow the crab starter,
they're hoping to catch a main course in their fishing net.
This one's very...wrunkled.
Have a quick look.
There's the butter.
There's a fish, there's a fish!
No.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Got a big one!
Wow!
Fuck me, what is it?
What is it?
It's huge!
It's a shark!
A shark!
He's still alive!
I need something to hit him with.
I need a big piece of wood.
OK, OK, I'll get it.
There's a bit of wood.
I've got it.
Ready?
Ok, good job, guys.
I hope everyone's hungry!
Right, come on, ladies.
Soapies!
Fish for breakfast, Fish for supper.
Nailing it!
Here, take this one.
That's delicious.
Foo Corn!
Look at the colour!
Thank you, all.
Foo Corn!
Thank you, all!
Right, I am.
Foo Corn!
Foxtrot, Foxtrot, this is Bravo, Emma.
This is Foxtrot.
I have for some news for you, ladies.
Tomorrow, a man called Bear will be coming to your island.
You are coming home.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Yay!
Wow!
We've got on the island and we've actually done it.
Well done. Well done.
It's mad. I feel numb and I feel fear.
You know when you've had, like, a near miss in the car or something...
Yeah. ..and you go like...
..like that, and then it hits and you go a bit numb
and you have to pull over cos you're a bit shaky? Yeah.
I feel like I've just been nearly hit.
It's a women's final night on the island.
OK, so we need to find some sort of cup. Do we have a sort of cup?
And there's much to celebrate.
Yeah.
Oh!
I got my ticket for the long way round
Two bottle whiskies by the way
And I sugar like some sweet company
And I'm leaving tomorrow, what do you say?
When I'm gone, when I'm gone
You're gonna miss me when I'm gone
You're gonna miss me by my hair
You're gonna miss me everywhere
Oh, you're still gonna miss me
When I'm gone
Life is either a great adventure or nothing.
As fast as we can!
We're a group of completely ordinary, down-to-earth women.
Oh!
You fucking snake, it came towards me!
It came right at me!
With no survival experience.
Fuck.
Oh my god, there's a caiman.
That is a big fucker.
We faced adversity every step of the way.
We cannot walk anywhere on this island without getting lost.
But we kept fighting.
Get the knife, get the knife!
You are not leaving this island till the fucking end game, right?
We were wet, cold and starving.
I just need to get some food. Just something.
Yet we found the strength
to keep pushing on.
Look at that little fire.
Fucking giant one!
Look at this!
If we hadn't have kept going,
it would have been the end.
In time, those memories will fade.
But what we will remember
are the women we experienced it with,
the friendships,
and how they made us feel.
Yeah!
We're winning.
Tomorrow, the women finally go home.
It's really weird.
We all feel so comfortable, in a way, with each other.
Sort of like a family.
I want to go home, but I don't want to leave.
I know.
I know what you mean.
Is that a boat? That's his boat.
Oh, my god.
We've never done this before.
14 women left on their own with nothing
in some of the harshest environments on the planet.
You know, they really are just ordinary people
from all walks of life.
Whoo!
And it hasn't just pushed them to the limits.
To be honest, it will have pushed them beyond that.
And what speaks volumes is that they're still there.
Whoo!
Yes!
Ten very grateful women.
Oh, god.
Oh, my god, it's actually happening.
It's actually happening.
This is amazing.
Whoo!
Wow.
Hi.
Welcome.
Wow.
Look at you.
Look at you guys.
This is how best it is.
Genuinely, what you've been through, respect.
Thank you.
You now understand this stuff is tough, you know?
Well done, you.
Well, welcome.
Wow, look at this. This is cool.
It's very cool. Here's our art installation.
And it's so clean.
I love this.
That's Harvey.
Thank you.
It's the little touches.
We've got a bed made of bottles
and a separate area for sitting and lounging around
and, you know, just generally hanging out.
This is so smart. It's getting you off the ground,
but it's communal.
Let's face it, girls, we like spoons, don't we?
We love a spoon. We love a spoon.
We've met the stereotype
with our decorations and our little feminine touches,
but totally blown it away
by the strength and the stamina
and the guts and the determination.
These women have got balls,
and big balls at last.
I would agree with that.
You ready to get the hell off this island?
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Dude! Dude!
If I hadn't turned up today,
and I turn up in six months,
I bet these guys would be in pretty good shape.
Oh, don't be mean to me.
Don't be mean to me.
And I knew it.
I knew the stereotype was wrong, you know?
But I knew they could nail this.
And for me, I'm so genuinely proud
of what they have achieved.
And they should be. And they are.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Woo!
Thank you.
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
Oh, my God!
I'm so proud of all of us that we've achieved this.
We have shown the world that women can achieve anything.
What I've learned is I need to appreciate
what I've got right now
and not strive to look for other better things.
I think it's made me more confident.
I've gained.
I've decided that I'm OK.
I'm not such a bad person.
I'm a good skin.
But being here, I felt so alive.
And I thought, God, this is me.
I feel happy.
And so, yeah, for me, I feel like this is it.
This is where I get something out of life.
And I want to run with it.
But I've survived for nearly two months,
and we've done it.
I can do any shit that I want.
And so can anybody else.
And it's brilliant.
We're amazing.
Woo!
We're nearly there!
Yes!
OK, ladies, welcome back to civilisation.
Yeah!
Oh!
I'm so glad I made it.
I can't believe I made it.
I'm getting emotional over that.
I've just been that brave.
I've been really brave.
Oh, for me.
The women have had no contact with the outside world
and loved ones for six weeks.
Hi, Mum.
Are you OK?
Yeah, it was amazing.
It was really fucking hard as well.
Hello?
Oh, my God!
Baby!
We can't wait to see you.
Yeah.
I've loved...
I've missed you all as well more than I ever imagined.
Hello, Daddy.
I've missed you so much.
Oh, God.
It's, like, sensational.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Having been stripped of any luxuries,
they're finally reintroduced to the modern world.
Oh, my God.
How nice does that feel?
What's this?
Ooh!
Oh!
What's it like?
Oh, look at my hair.
Amazing.
The way it cuts your bottom.
What the hell?
My eyebrows!
God, it's so clear.
Oh, my God.
It's so clean.
I love clean, being clean, you know.
This is amazing!
The women's bodies are in a fragile state,
and for the first three days, they must stick to a simple diet.
No!
That drinks.
Yay!
That is great.
Thank you very much.
Is this chicken?
Oh!
Yes, it is.
Even the smell of the rice.
It's so good.
Oh, my God.
I mean, it's so good.
It's so good.
This is good.
It's our first meal off the island, girls.
Cheers!
This experiment ultimately shows that, really, it isn't about gender.
It's about attitude.
Some people have that heart and mind of a survivor.
Determined, team players,
hard-working, resourceful.
What these ordinary women have been through genuinely is remarkable.
They've endured unbelievable hardships
and they've come out of it empowered and positive.
And for that, they've won my respect.
Big time.
It's like the best company ever, isn't it?
Hello!
You can't just come off a boat and stay in the same place.
Please, walk!
Walk!
Next time, it's the final instalment of the men's island.
I'm going to go to hell for this.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
I'm a scorpion.
People are just starting not to give a shit anymore.
Come on, boys!
Son!
Mother Nature and this island will bite you whenever she feels fit.
It only starts on the first week of the trip.
Suzanne, stay here!
I'll meet you in my cell.
Hey, Dan!
Thar...
Humph!
It's a poder safety method,
I'd say it's about time.
Not yet.
The options are like that.
You dirty seagulls.
It'd be happiness for me to know
what exactly those seagulls think about that labor.
Some get by time to get the farm going.
If you are going to do it,
start in the headaches.
If you continue to work with a double,
not an founders' job.
You deal with it.